what I find particularly upsetting is
not just what's happening to people who
have been working their whole lives in
the auto industry but also that the
United Auto Workers you know founded by
the Reuther brothers to me were kind of
like the you know the Harvard and Yale
of the labor union movement and its
really a testament to them that auto
workers were able to work and have
careers and really be middle class and
really do well and you know in the
middle of all of this situation and our
whole economy is essentially this view
that there's something in that that's
not workable and I think some pieces of
that may very well not be workable and
some pieces of that I think are showing
what what the next phase of our economy
is going to look like and by that I mean
if you look at Detroit as one of our
large economic centers in this country
you had a whole group of people who
could afford a lot of things and paid a
lot of taxes and supported a whole lot
of other industries all brought to you
in large part by the United Auto Workers
and so we have to be careful that we
don't you know kill the patient by
curing you know one one piece of this
this problem so I think it is a good
thing that the Obama administration is
recognizing that this is really nuanced
this isn't just about fixing the auto
industry per se but that it's a whole
ecosystem and system together
of course I wish I had like a very short
and pithy answer to that but you know my
hunch is that because this is called
like big think big ideas that we're
realizing that you can't expect a
certain rate of return on manufacturing
in the auto industry and expect to have
one in America that is that we can't
have private equity rates of return of
eighteen to thirty five percent and that
we're going to have to be thinking that
there's something important about having
certain industries and there's going to
be a governmental role in keeping these
alive that it's crucial that we make
things in America and I think this is
the beginning of that realization i
think that people are starting to see
there's something important here i think
sometimes people think this is just
about bailing out the auto industry you
know beginning middle and end and done i
think hopefully there are people who are
saying wow there is something deeper
here that we need to understand that
government can be a source of capital or
can subsidize some parts of capital or
compare some pizza the risk because we
recognize that it's really important to
have a middle class in America and I
think that's really what's at stake you
know we may very well come out of this
but the question is are we going to come
out of it looking you know like
Argentina you know with a very small
group of rich people in a very large
group of everybody else and I don't
think that's what America is about
I just think that's just factually wrong
if you say that there are elements in
terms of the costs of health and
pensions which i think is true then
that's a piece of it you know it's also
a piece of not having a government
strategy that says we don't care that
Americans may very well when asked say
they want the biggest behemoth cars and
you know that they can get their hands
on but that's not why we have government
leaders and that you know one of the
reasons why people want bigger cars is
because other people have big cars and
it's not just because they're pigs you
know I have a child and I know that when
I go out and I want to make sure she's
okay and when kids are very young do you
have to make sure that the airbags are
one thing and another thing and having
everybody having SUVs is just like a big
arms race and government has to start
saying that that's not acceptable and
those are the kinds of things that I
think we need to do is to start having
some public policy about what's
acceptable what isn't acceptable if
you're still going to go out and need to
have a big hulking automobile you should
be paying a lot of extra fees associated
with that you know I think we need to be
looking at the incentives and the
disincentives
no I really feel bad because 20 million
just doesn't buy what it used to but you
know what i think is more profound i
think it's really easy to just be angry
at all these CEOs you know we're so
angry at them and they live in Greenwich
Connecticut and blah blah blah but we
set up the rules of the game and when I
say we I mean like the citizens allowed
this to happen over the last 25 years
that we said the job of any good CEO is
to get maximum return on investment
period it doesn't matter sort of how
they do it and if any of them show
restraint then we're going to punish
them and you saw that that happened with
the CEO of home depot who you know now
looks like a genius but you know in the
last five or seven years he said I think
it's important to pay people wages that
you know our good solid wages with
benefits and there was been a whole
debate about was that ok because was he
maximizing shareholder returns so I
think that we really have to stop and
say did we set up the rules of the game
so that these people just played it that
way and then I think having said that
and I think that really is the bulk of
it I think that we as a society have to
hold ourselves responsible for certain
things and that part of that is that we
really believe that was in our right to
really use up the earth's resources in a
way and be very wealthy and have
state-of-the-art kitchens and fancy
things and these corporate CEOs were
just the worst of it you know but it's
something that I think we see all over
the place and I think it's a culture of
greed that I think is bad